hello thank you everyone for joining us
today
i'm constable rob carver public
information officer with the winnipeg
police service
just one matter to talk about
yesterday evening at about 9 10 p.m
winnipeg police were advised of a motor
vehicle collision
near broadway and memorial boulevard the
initial information was that a westbound
jeep patriot had driven through a group
of protesters that were part of the
freedom convoy at the legislative
grounds
the jeep then fled west ultimately going
down portage avenue where numerous
witnesses reported it traveling at high
rates of speed and passing through red
lights
with the assistance of the rcmp winnipeg
police service officers were able to
stop the vehicle in the 4800 block of
portage avenue at approximately 10 30.
the lone male driver was arrested after
a brief struggle
the jeep struck four adult males in
total three sustained minor injuries
that did not require medical attention
and that's actually not quite accurate
they were treated at the scene by
winnipeg fire paramedic service and the
fourth was treated in hospital and
released
as a result a 42 year old male from
headingley manitoba faces charges of
assault with a weapon times four
dangerous operation of a
conveyance-caused bodily harm times two
dangerous operation of a conveyance
failed to stop after accident knowing
that reckless knowing that the driving
was reckless times two and failed to
stop at the scene of an accident times
two
and he is currently in custody we
haven't named the individual yet because
charges haven't been formally sworn to
and we are obligated to not release a
name until that process is complete
um i guess i'll take questions
uh jen from bloomberg news hello jen
hi i had a really difficult time hearing
the audio
i'm not sure
but anyway thanks for taking my question
i'm just wondering if you can comment on
the motivation of the driver in the team
yeah it's it's always really difficult
and i'm asked this question often to
attribute
a particular motivation to someone's
actions
what i can tell you here is that some
comments were made by the accused that
sends tends to suggest
that this was not specifically about the
mandates
i don't have a lot more information but
i i think that might be important for
the media and the public to understand
now whether or not we can we can
sort of rely on those comments uh is
another question and
the individual was uh was taken into
custody with some resistance so
this was not someone who was compliant
and the comments
were blurted out but as i i will repeat
it
it looks like the
actions were not
really as a result of the mandates
i guess what can you say about
intentions or the
[Music]
um
we don't i mean we're prepared we're
always prepared for uh
the potential of violence in situations
like this we have officers at the scene
and we will continue to maintain
wps presence at the scene
until this is over
we have been in constant touch with the
organizers on scene
we uh
we are not making any changes per se in
terms of our uh stance uh i know that as
of this morning
uh protesters on scene have
moved some trucks and that broadway is
now down to one lane uh in either
direction
um
i think giving people in the area some
more um
some more security limiting traffic flow
and and we've put out on uh on twitter
that
we're asking people to you know if you
don't have to be in the area if with a
vehicle then don't
there's a lot of stuff going on and if
you are part of it
or you have to be in the area then
expect some delays traveling in that
area but other than that we're not
this was really a one-off i believe
uh abigail from global
hi there sorry i can't really hear you
that well i i'm just wondering um if
there's any thoughts or reasoning behind
not just completely closing off the
streets so there's no issue of
traffic
getting involved in situations like this
a uh
that's a really
tough decision to make first of all
there are people who who want to be part
of this
protest and and are coming to the area
for that reason and we need to
facilitate
their ability to peacefully protest
we also need to make sure that
people can get in and out of that area
in the general downtown area of for
either regular commutes or emergency
needs
and there are there are people who want
to come by and give support or you know
media are trying to get in so we're
trying to balance those needs with um
with
making it safe but still allowing um
still allowing some vehicular traffic
this is an important area of winnipeg
and while it is the weekend uh it
becomes heavy traffic flow during monday
to friday during commutes
we're trying to balance all of those
needs
not only people who live in the city but
people who are trying to to
express their views and protests in the
area
and i'm not sure if this is too close to
the motivation question
but i'm wondering if this person
had plans
on coming and hitting a person or is
this a spur of the moment is it too soon
to answer that
it is too soon we don't have that answer
in investigations like this i mean
unless he
unless he chooses to divulge that we may
never get an answer to that
uh jill from cbc
hi there i wonder if you can speak a
little bit further on this when you say
it's not believed to be about the
mandate does it believe that the accused
was was participating in the protest no
no no absolutely not no the accused was
not participating in the protest what
some comments he made
after his arrest
suggested that
his motivation was not specifically
about
the underlying causes of the protest or
the mandates that's about as far as i
can get
i i know it's a bit obscure but i i'm
really limited in in terms of we don't
really go into into individuals
motivation i think it's important here
to give some context that he wasn't
really for or against
uh either of the general views that are
sort of floating around this country
other than that i can't give you a lot
have police encountered any other
violence or incidents
similar in nature directed at or
involving protesters
we have not and i can tell you that we
are in uh
very regular contact
with uh with protesters and the
organizers and and everyone is being
incredibly cooperative and we've had
no issues
other than this
this particular one uh
luckily no one was seriously hurt but
nothing other than this it has been uh
it has been quite
well managed and
we'd like to thank everybody involved
for their continued cooperation it has
it has really made uh
the police job much easier and and made
it easier in the citizens of winnipeg
glenn from sun
um yeah um
rob can you speak to whether
you
have there been any kind of
effort made to
much like a construction zone to set up
something to slow the traffic down or
has that been considered by the police
we haven't made any changes to how we
were
deployed in the area
since the start of this protest on
friday morning
we view it as an evolving situation like
any protest we will continue to not only
monitor it but work with organizers and
i want to stress that we are working
with organizers
as i said earlier some some trucks were
repositioned
mid-morning today to enhance what
organizers felt
was the safety of of people in the area
if
if we see
a situation arise or or
events arise that we need to work with
them to do further enhancements we will
certainly do that and we are prepared
but that hasn't taken place
um
i know there's a video been posted on
twitter
has have your officers
had a chance to view the video yet and
are you asking for any additional
you know anyone with dashboard cam or
any kind of video as well
no our officers had access to that uh to
that video as well as other digital
information uh
fairly soon after the incident uh our
investigation is complete uh the
individuals in custody were really not
looking for any further information uh
people who were at the scene were very
helpful both
both dash cam and cell phone videos and
we'd like to thank everybody who came
forward at the time
again we're just thankful that that no
one sustained any uh serious or
life-altering injuries but we we're not
going to need any more assistance now
it's concluded
uh devin from ctv
i was wondering uh is there any concerns
with
uh seeing something like this happen
again in the future or or even
the flip side of having some
not um
i think police everywhere and
specifically in winnipeg view these
situations as potentially volatile
there are strong
uh strong opinions being expressed
expressed
and there are a broad range there's
there's polarization here anytime you
have a situation like that there's
there's a potential for
for tempers to flare and and
and and possibly some violence
we have done everything we can
uh or are prepared to do at this point
to ensure the safety of people in the
area again we're working with organizers
and
and collaboratively we feel that the
current situation uh is is balancing
everyone's needs and safety
do you have a follow-up devin
yeah i was just wondering um
whether
it was motivated
by the protest or just as you know
swirled the
for the moment
look at
increasing the police presence in the
area at all
certainly
the potential is there to do that but as
i've spoken to we are working
collaboratively with people on scene and
and organizers
if if additional police resources were
required to enhance the safety
we'd certainly be looking at that that's
not the consensus at this point
maggie from the free press
so i'm wondering if you know how fast
the girl was traveling
uh
i'm not going to speak to it but the
videos all over social media you can
take a look for yourself it's uh
it it was moving at a fairly decent clip
and it's uh
it's pretty
miraculous that nobody sustained any any
serious injuries
uh i i've seen the video i haven't
uh i haven't spoken to
traffic collision investigators to have
their assessment of the speed
they're able to do that probably from
the video but it's it's moving at a
pretty decent clip
and since
these protesters arrived on the scene
yesterday
do you have an estimate of how many
people have been participating since
um it's it's been somewhat fluid my my
understanding uh last night there was
somewhere around um 100 people on scene
some estimates of i think if i'm correct
about 40 to 50 vehicles
that was increasing this morning as we
would expect
during daylight hours more people coming
into the area some more vehicles
again i would like to say that everyone
has been
very peaceful very cooperative with us
very prepared to engage in dialogue with
our officers
i i don't know you know looking at some
news feats from across the country uh
you know it's winnipeg and it's lots of
blowing snow and it's
pretty chilly out there still i think
that affects people's
inclination to come out and uh and stay
outside
but we'll have to see
uh liza from radio canada
will be
tuesday you're working with the
organizer for those that are saying
around the lake the mage uh
do you know if a protester are planning
to leave any scientist
we haven't
been given any indication
when the protesters are planning to
leave or if they're planning to leave
the current situation from our
standpoint is quite stable
and and that's not first and foremost on
our mind unlike some other cities
this is uh uh
everyone is cooperating well and uh
uh
we're not looking at at some sort of
end as how we can uh or an end date as
to when things will wrap up we just want
to make sure everyone is safe while it's
ongoing
and other than this incident
which we which we believe is one-off uh
we hope to be able to continue with the
level of safety we've seen
do you have a
follow-up so you're not planning to
increase the security around the village
or the area
well we have no plans to change uh our
our deployment model at this point other
than last night
and i think anytime you've got people on
streets and and
and vehicles
there is
a potential we can't
we can't block off roads
in the downtown area to make sure that
people who are walking to and from this
area are safe
uh
protesters understand
and and i think if you see the video
are cognizant of the fact that they're
on roadways that uh that even if we
blocked off you know even a broadway was
blocked off there are cross streets uh
that that have the potential for
um you know vehicular pedestrian
interactions
uh
we don't see that that
anything
any changes to our model
would enhance anyone's safety
rob from canadian press
up there does anyone else have any
further questions
well if that's
just wondering do we know if
this person has admitted a crime or
during the day in the spleen or do they
have any criminal history at all
as far as i'm aware the person had no uh
no previous police involvement and this
was not related to any other criminal
offense nope
rob can you say
if this incident
was
believed to be targeted or intentional
against the protesters
um
it does appear that way yes
we know that
at least one of the of the victims was
wearing a hi-vis vest
if you watch the video
on social media you can see that
vehicles are are moving through the area
at a safe pace
protesters are aware of of the vehicles
they're facilitating the passing of the
vehicles and this vehicle
is is on broadway westbound
and appears to
accelerate from the
from the pedestrian crosswalk just east
of there
i i can't speculate other than what i've
seen in the video and what investigators
have told me but it certainly does look
like there was some intention here
i know you mentioned that there have
been no other incidents that i spoke
with a woman this morning
said she was harassed by an anti-vaxxer
outside near the protest yesterday
afternoon are you aware of that incident
have there been any reports
so i'm not but as i said earlier this is
an extremely polarizing um
situation
there are very divergent views not only
here but across the country beyond that
and i i
i'm not sure what the definition of
harassment is but people with
strongly held beliefs get pretty
passionate about those beliefs and those
sorts of interactions really don't
become police matters unless they become
criminal so if you're
if you know if you're on one side of the
fence or the other
everybody needs to be
reminded except they've been doing this
well
these are strongly held in impassioned
views
and they're going to be expressed with a
lot of
passion so i i'm not sure what the
definition of harassment is and
but that's the nature of this political
discourse
um rob glenda atkinson
um anyone driving through the area would
you have any words of advice for them if
they're being held up by the protest or
if they're
getting a little hot under the caller
what would your words to them be
well glenn we put out on on twitter
today a reminder that you know
really if you don't need to be in that
area then then pick another route to
travel through you know we've got a
we've got a number of of protesters
and and vehicles slowing traffic
you don't need to take that route and
find a different route if you have to
take the route or you're in the area
because of your
um
beliefs then be prepared to be delayed
and there's no sense getting
short-tempered about it it
traffic will be delayed and and if it's
ongoing past the weekend and into a
monday morning commute
there will continue to be delays um i'd
like to stress that
delays are something that that anybody
in an urban center
has been used to over over the last
decade in terms of political concerns
and and i'd like
to make sure that everyone understands
that it's
a delay is a small inconvenience we
haven't shut down parts of of downtown
we haven't limited traffic we haven't
eliminated traffic flow and and again
i'd like to thank everybody involved for
their cooperation um
delays are going to be expected and
and and patients are going to be
required
anything further from any reporter
thank you thank you very much
you